you're listening to episode
two of storycast 21 i'm jane secker
on july the 3rd 2010 a double shooting
in the northeast of england
and the pursuit of the gunman that
followed dominated international
headlines for seven days
this is the hunt for raul moat
i'm susan the former chief constable of
northumbria
on the 3rd of july i was
in overall command of northumbria police
i was at home i'd gone to bed as normal
my eldest daughter and husband were
in bed
and then i received that fateful call it
was in the early hours of the morning
that police were called to this
normally quiet area of berkeley on the
outskirts of chester
street it was the silver commander who
phoned me to say
that there had been a shooting they
arrived to find a scene
of brutal violence according to
eyewitnesses
i lived in newcastle so across
the river tyne the next metropolitan
district
is gateshead and it was in that area
that moat shot
chris brown and sam starbart i heard the
bang
bang i thought it was windows at first
you know and now seeing that it was just
terrible
exactly did you see that my
understanding is
that the former boyfriend of sam stop
art
had in a fit of jealousy
shot and murdered chris brown
and seriously injured
sam starbart police say the man they are
looking for in connection with these
shootings
is raul thomas moat we believe the
offender target
i believed that what we had to do then
was just
to locate raul moat
i did not in any way shape or form
expect it to turn into
the incident that it did hello there
this is big gunman from berkeley last
night
my name is
i'm lisa dowd and i'm a correspondent
for sky news
time ago lisa dowd is at the scene of
the double shooting
in berkeley for us and lisa what's the
latest information that you have
well police forensic teams have really
been searching
for raumote was 37 and a former
nightclub bouncer from phenom in
newcastle
he'd been in a relationship with
samantha staubart but they'd broken up
when moat was in jail for assault and he
was recently released
from durham prison in fact released from
durham
on thursday well detectives i remember
thinking
that samantha starbart must have been
absolutely terrified
raul mode had been crouching under the
living room window
as they came out of the house he opened
fire
and shot her boyfriend chris brown now
she
ran back into the house but you could
see from
the ground floor window into the lounge
he had shot
through that window hitting
samantha stubbart as she tried to take
cover
she is currently in hospital in a pretty
bad condition but police have told us
she will survive and they are at payne's
shots forward now
uh they're telling the public that they
would put in
a call to northumbria police
to say that he was going to shoot
police officers and what i'm talking
about is to tell you exactly why i've
done what i've done
[ __ ] the value is i'm not coming in the
line you just passed with me for
i mean i'll tell 20 this raumote had
promised not to stop until he was dead
and then in the early hours of sunday
that
investigation really escalated an
officer was shot in the early hours of
this morning he was carrying out a
static patrol
on a roundabout we understood
at porsche's one in the morning i got a
phone call
which was the worst phone call
of my professional life he was shot
through the windscreen
uh into the face and chest he's now in
hospital in a critical
but stable condition he has ten and a
half years david rathband was sitting
waiting and hoping to actually stop
raul moat and he'd been sitting
at a roundabout on the a1 a69
junction i looked to my left
through the the um
front passenger side of my police car
and i saw
mulch money from the a1 he lifted the
gun pushed it forward
and then discharged the weapon through
my my window
i felt all the pain and it was the
the shotgun um cartridge going through
my eye socket between my two eyes
round oats had gone up to him
and had callously shot him in the head
which resulted in in david being blinded
we are absolutely committed to finding
the man who did this
and are using every resource available
to bring this to a conclusion as quickly
as possible
nobody really knew what this man was
going to do
next
we had a gunman on the run the man
we are looking for is raul thomas
moat a very good morning to you welcome
to sunrise on monday the 5th of july our
top story
gunman on the run for the whole of
monday
the 5th of july into the tuesday
my focus was that crime scene at
berkeley we're live at the scene of one
of the shootings this is police
friends i remember police putting out
some detail
on a black lexus car that they thought
moat was using
we're live from rothbury and
northumberland where britain's both
now police found this black lexus at
rothbury
and immediately set up this huge
exclusion zone
around the town and i got straight into
the car
and started heading north detective
leading the hunt
for rao motor warned that the suspected
killer has
made threats against the public now
contradicting their earlier theory that
he
only posed to danger to police here this
massive
well my biggest fears of course
and my first objective was
to make sure that he was detained
and brought to justice before a court
for his crimes
and that was the one thing that i wanted
as well as
keeping the community and the police
officers safe
we knew that he had gone to ground in
rothbury what i was concerned about
was the fact that we were unable to
locate him
rothbury is in northumberland
and where moat was
is one of the most densely wooded
and least populated
parts of northumberland
i think at that point it felt like
the police were assembling a small army
if you like
in the most unlikely of places
there were reinforcements coming in from
all over the country
250 of them were armed and
they'd set up this two mile exclusion
zone
with roadblocks everywhere you couldn't
get in or out of that town
without your car being searched
i remember my mum leaving me a voicemail
telling me to be careful we were
reporting at times from
some quite remote locations and we had
no
idea where moat was was he watching us
and at one point there was some
discussion from our team
in london as to whether we needed flak
jackets
protective jackets sending up to us
we're right to say aren't we i think
that some more military equipment has
been brought to bear on this manhunt as
well
i'd be doing a live report at a remote
farm one minute and i'd look over my
shoulder
and i'd spot the sun glinting off
one of the helmets of the firearms
officers who would be
in formation kind of stalking down the
side of a hillside in full protective
gear
in the skies there was this kind of
deafening roar of jets around dusk
it was clear that there were tornado
jets well
raf jets flying quite slowly over
rothbery
we understand that they were being used
to photograph or video
the terrain to try and spot any sign of
where
he had been
here this massive search operation has
now run into its six days so far though
no sight or sign of the fugitive
live now to sky's mind i think one of
the things that did cause me
some angst was that some of my
male chief constable colleagues had
decided
that i didn't have the experience
because i was only a temporary chief
constable
i had the then home secretary
parisa may called me when david rathband
had been shot
and her advisers phoned me on a daily
basis
just to remind you again if you've just
switched on a raul mo the man that
northumbria police with the help of at
least 11 other police forces
have been pursuing has been found he has
been surrounded by armed police
and there is i'll step out of the shop
it was around seven o'clock
at night and i remember seeing
journalists and some of the locals
rushing towards the riverbank area in
the town
one of the community officers had gone
down to the riverbank and have actually
seen
raul mode and had called the firearms in
to surround him and to start negotiating
with him i wasn't aware of that at that
time
i had left rothbury just
after six o'clock
and as we got down to the a1 the
assistant chief constable
called me and said sue we've got him
surrounded
on the riverbank and there is a
negotiation going on between
the two parties ralmot on one side
carrying his uh
a weapon to his throat and the police on
the other side
this was the moment everything had been
building towards
some officers were taking cover behind
armored vehicles there were snipers with
rifles
some of them were literally standing in
the river
using anywhere to try and get a site of
moat
it's seven days since moat allegedly
shot and wounded
his former girlfriend samantha stobart
and killed her new partner
chris brown they thought raul moat was
going to kill
again and they were throwing everything
at it to try and stop him negotiations
between police
and moat are continuing moat has been
given food and water
and is eating and so i headed straight
into
the headquarters into the gold command
and i stayed there
my sole objective
was to capture ralmate
and to push him before a court it has
now been confirmed that the
footballer paul gascoigne has arrived
uh claiming to be a friend of ralmotz
and bring it with you there was this
kind of jaw-dropping moment paul
gascoigne
gaza one of britain's best-known
footballers
turned up at the cordon wanting to talk
to moat
wanting to help the situation but the
police
would not entertain the idea uh a
friendly face if you like
for uh uh this man rail mode paul
gascoigne the footballer apparently
as the night wore on no one really knew
how long this standoff was going to last
so i made my way back to one of the
local hotels that we've been put up in
what's happening kay is that police are
talking to ralph mort
covering him i turned on the television
and there's my colleague james matthews
reporting from the scene at the cordon
what you're looking at
are armed officers there's something and
you can see the silhouettes of the armed
officers moving around
with the green and grainy shots filmed
from our night vision camera
then there's what sounds like a shot
bear with me a second james matthews
with us james the latest
yeah okay i'm gonna hold the microphone
in the air we've just had a shot
i was sat in the gold command thing
and all of a sudden the call
came out shocked fired
and for a split second do you think
who shot who who shot who
[Music]
and it became clear very very quickly
that real mate had shot himself
and the ambulance was down there they
took him to the
hospital where he was declared dead
had shot himself at 12 minutes past one
in the morning
on july the 10th a post-mortem
examination
carried out the day after found that he
died from a shot
from his sworn-off shotgun
it was certainly one of the most
troubling
stories i've covered in my career
i've reported on a lot of murders
a lot of shootings but with this case it
was
so hard to predict where it was going to
go next and
in that scenario it meant who might be
killed next i live with the outcome i
live with the fact
we couldn't bring him to justice for the
families
of the people that he'd hurt
would like to give as i did at the time
my condolences to the family
of chris brown
to kath russband and the children of
david rathband for his
terrible death following
this incident and to some stubborn
for the injuries that she had they were
also
the innocent victims of this man
[Music]
sadly pc david rathband never recovered
from his injuries
he died by suicide in february 2012.
for more on this documentary go to
www.skynews.com
forward slash storycast 21.
the hunt for ral moat was written and
produced by robert mulhern
recordings research and production from
tom gillespie
next time i think i was like a boxer and
it doesn't
know whether i will be knocked out or he
will win by
points or in vienna as a kenyan athlete
attempts the impossible four-time london
marathon winner eliot kipchoge
hoping to become the first person in
history to run a marathon
in under two hours